[MUSIC PLAYING]
JUSTIN BECKWITH: All right.
Well, the music turned off.
And that guy told
me that I'm supposed
to come up on stage now.
So let's have a
talk about security.
Yay!
Congratulations, everyone.
You made it.
It's the last day
of the conference.
When I think about
the kind of topics
I want to hear about when it's
the last day of a conference--
I'm tired, I'm
having a good time.
I just had lunch, I'm
warm-- full belly.
Security in the cloud is not
exactly the most exciting thing
in the world to everyone.
So I want to thank you all.
I'll do my best not
to put you to sleep.
We're going to have
some fun today.
We're going to look
at a couple of demos,
talk about some problems,
and hopefully make
some bad decisions along
the way because that's where
we actually learn our lessons.
Before we get all into that,
my name is Justin Beckwith.
I'm an engineering
manager at Google.
A lot of the demos that
we're going to look at today,
you're going to be
able to find on GitHub.
If you want to reach out to me
or get into contact with any
of the teams that make the cool
products that I'm going to talk
about today, then all of my
contact information is there.
Feel free to reach out.
For those of us in the
information security field,
this has been kind
of a rough year.
It's been a hard year to watch.
We've seen multiple
high-profile breaches.
I'm going to not
do those companies
the disservice of
putting their logos here
or any of the news clippings.
But we've seen several
incidents where
companies were careless
with their customers' data.
This is a real problem.
And the worst part
is it's something
that we tend to think as
engineers, or as IT admins,
or [? Cis ?] admins,
we tend to think
that it's a problem that we
can just solve with technology.
There's a specific
product that can
help us lock it down this way.
There's a specific thing
that we can use here.
While, in some
cases, that's true,
the truth is this is really
a consumer trust problem.
Because the moment that we
take on a customer's data,
and they've made the
relationship with us,
they've trusted us with that
data, and then we lose it,
we have a breach, that
relationship, oftentimes,
is impossible to repair.
It's not something that
we, as business owners,
can ever get back.
The impact globally,
according to a recent report
of an average data breach,
is about $4 million.
Now this is average, going
anywhere from a small security
breach-- which no one likes to
think any of them are a small
deal--
all the way up to something
like what happened with Equifax
where the effects are going
to ripple for quite some time.
And that's not anything that
any of us want on our watch.
It's not something anybody wants
to expose their customers to.
The truth is,
security, information,
security in the
Cloud with user data,
this is a business problem.
Once that trust is lost, it's
not coming back, not easily.
We need 10 positive
interactions to make up
for one negative interaction.
And if you loose
someone's customer data,
and they lose their
social security number
and have identity
fraud, then, well, it's
going to take maybe more
than 10 good interactions.
But good news!
There are no magic bullets.
There's not one thing that's
going to fix this for us.
And if anyone's
trying to sell you
one thing that's going to
fix security in the cloud,
you probably shouldn't
buy from them.
Nothing is going to
make you 100% secure.
But what we can do is we can
identify the most common risk
factors, the highest
risk factors,
and we can reduce that risk.
We can mitigate the
highest risk factors.
And that's largely what we're
going to talk about today.
We're going to be taking a look
at preventing and mitigating
known vulnerabilities
in our software
stack through containers,
through virtual machines,
through the software that
we're actually running inside
of our applications, and find
what are some of the most
common ways that they
can be compromised,
and how can we mitigate that?
How can we reduce the surface
area for a potential attack?
When I talk about
vulnerability protection,
I like to think about this
in three different buckets.
The first place, where not a
lot of people really think about
is at code time.
Increasingly, the software
that we're building
and that our software
teams are building
are comprised of
third-party components.
It's not like it used to
be where you would have one
giant standard library,
you'd build your application,
you write 100% of
the code, and you
know exactly what's in there.
How many of us here
are using something
like MPM, Maven, PIP, GoGet,
any GoGet packages, Composer?
There's one of these--
every language ecosystem has
a third-party ecosystem
that, increasingly,
has become critical to the
success of our software.
So for all of those people that
raised hands, how many of you
read over every line of
code that you're importing
into your application?
That's amazing!
I want to talk--
I want to know
how to scale that.
We need tools.
We need better tools
to tell us, yes, we
want to enable our
developers to be successful,
and to go build great
things, and use what's
out there in the community.
At the same time,
we need to make sure
that there are no known
vulnerabilities, and that,
honestly, in a lot
of cases, that we
have the appropriate
licenses in place.
Because it becomes, not
just a security issue,
but a compliance issue as well.
The next phase of vulnerability
prevention comes at build time.
And this is where, if you're
containerized organization,
there are a lot of great
options for you out there.
Because we've
started to take what
used to be purely
at the deployment
time and the
infrastructure stage,
and we can now pull
that all the way back
into our build-time processes.
I want to know what
operating system are we
using, which distribution,
which version, what packages
are installed?
Can I compare those
packages against a list
of known vulnerabilities?
And then lastly, once I
have all of that information
about the build, can I
give it, in my CI system,
the good old thumbs up or
the-- wah, wah-- thumbs down.
And that brings me to the
last part of vulnerability
prevention-- deployment time.
So you've built your
container, you've
built your application
binary, you're
ready to send it
into production.
What are we doing at
prod time to make sure
that it's done all that
other checks and all
those other things
we said it would do?
How do I know that there
are no third-party packages
or vulnerabilities?
How do I know that
we did a scan?
How do I know that my build
system is the one that
produced that build?
How do I know this isn't
just an arbitrary binary
that one of my developers made
on their local machine who
possibly is disgruntled, or they
had an attack on their desktop?
These are all questions we need
to think about at each phase
through our software
development lifecycle process
to be able to reduce that
surface area of attacks.
Today, we're largely going
to be talking about build
time and deployment
time as it relates
to containers and Kubernetes.
So lastly, security-- it's
easy to say, oh, this company
had a huge breach.
They were negligent;
individuals were negligent.
It tends not to be
a people problem.
It's not that any one person
wasn't doing their job.
It tends to be a
process problem.
We need to ask the
questions, how do
we know our software is secure?
How do we know it's
verified in the build?
And then how do we know if
there are any new ones once it's
already in production?
It's not enough just
to stop vulnerabilities
from getting into production.
We have to react
after they're there.
And for each of
these phases, we need
to have a well-defined process
and a set of tools that helps
us commit to that process.
And that's what we're
going to talk about today.
It's a process problem.
And I'm going the
wrong direction.
Let's go this way.
All right.
So now, we've done a lot of
talking, a lot of talking.
I want to show how some
potentially benign-looking
applications can actually expose
pretty significant holes that
allow you to take down an app.
So we're going to talk about
my terrible, horrible, no
good, very bad day.
"This is a fictitious story.
This did not actually happen.
Any similarity to any production
service living or dead
is merely coincidental."
All right.
So a fairly typical
application architecture
that you might find
in Google Cloud
is going to be run on
top of Kubernetes--
Kubernetes Engine in my case.
I have a front end service
that's individually scalable.
I have a back end
service that's scalable.
The two are connected via gRPC.
We have the Cloud Vision API,
I have Cloud storage for files,
I have some other
random API here off
in the distance
that I'm calling.
But in terms of a typical
business application that's
being built in a containerized
workflow, this is it.
And this is the type of app
that we're going to look at
and how I actually personally
made some pretty bad mistakes
when I built the app
that we're going to see.
And of course, my
boss is over there
saying he totally trusts me.
He's positive I'm going to
build this mission-critical app,
and it completely won't have
100 vulnerabilities that'll
tank the business.
I appreciate his
confidence in me.
I don't know if he's
out there or not.
And so our totally
mission-critical business
application is going
to be about cats.
This is actually my cat.
That's Boo Boo Bad Kitty.
And can we move
over to the demo?
It's going to look--
I actually don't know if it's
the demo because it looks
exactly the same as the slide.
That's interesting.
But I can see my mouse moving
around, so I feel pretty good.
So what this mission-critical
business application does is,
it's actually going
out to Reddit.
It's downloading
images from r/aww,
which is cute animal pictures
if you've never seen it.
And then it's categorizing
them into two buckets.
On the left, we have cats, and
on the right, we have dogs.
And it's using the Cloud Vision
API to figure that out and sort
it all together.
So it looks like the dogs are
out to a bit of an early lead.
We have the cute dog
with the watermelon.
There are puppies.
Cats are falling a litt--
oh, a literal box of cats.
That's just going
to count as one.
Like I said here, this is
very important to the business
because we're trying to
make people productive.
I need cute pictures of
animals to stay happy.
If I'm not happy,
I'm not productive,
therefore, business critical.
We have the Leia cat.
And look at that.
Dogs win.
[APPLAUSE]
That was half hearted.
Come on, let's hear it for dogs.
Fun fact-- I wrote this
app three years ago.
Dogs always win.
It's the weirdest thing.
And I actually have
years of data in BigQuery
to prove it if
anybody's interested.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Let's go back to the slides.
Actually-- so this is a
pretty simple application.
All of this is really doing,
for the front end container,
it's using an out-of-the-box
Node.js container that I found
on Docker Hub.
I went on Docker Hub, I searched
for one, it looked fine,
I used it.
I-- [LAUGHS] Yeah.
Exactly.
[LAUGHS] This is
three years ago.
Give me a break.
I expose a port on it, and
I run the final command.
So knowing what I know now that
I've been at Google for a while
and kind of going back and
trying to fix that, it just
so happens that the
container I had used
had a couple of
minor vulnerabilities
in the distribution of
Debian it was using.
It's using a version
of Node.js that
is completely out of support,
not receiving any security
updates.
None of the third-party
components of the MPM models
I was using are getting patched.
And it's just been
kind of hanging around.
So let's go over to a demo
and see what we can do.
This is always fun.
Can we go to the demo?
Yay!
There we go.
All right.
So this is the source.
And this particular
version of Debian unpatched
was susceptible to a
neat little trip attack.
So I can run attack.sh.
We're going to wait.
Hopefully, this is not
a problem for the Wi-Fi.
We're going to open a
bunch of HTTP connections,
but we're not
going to send data.
We're just going to
slowly drip, drip,
drip bits of data with a
bunch of open connections.
Let it warm up.
All right.
So we did it.
So I'm going to open a new tab.
And let's see.
If I go to cats.jbeckwith.com--
I've never given a
demo where the point
was for the demo not to work.
[LAUGHS] This is new for me.
We did it!
[LAUGHTER]
I was able, with a
simple Bash script,
to take down my own site.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You're
sure it's on Wi-Fi?
[LAUGHTER]
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Oh, yes.
I mean, this conference
Wi-Fi is terrible.
It's always causing problems.
So let's cancel that out.
We're going to give in a
minute, let my service breathe.
It's on Kubernetes.
So the good news is that,
after everything falls down,
the pods will probably restart.
And if the attack has
stopped-- and I'm back.
All right.
So that's-- can we
go back to the deck?
So that's not good.
That is very bad.
This is not what we
want to have happening
for any of the applications that
we are responsible for running.
So how could this
have been avoided?
To help avoid issues
like this, that's
why Google is working on
the Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanner.
Say that three times fast.
Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanner.
I'm not going to try.
Now the Vulnerability Scanner,
it will detect vulnerabilities
before deploying to production.
Today, the types of
vulnerabilities for detecting
are in operating systems,
operating system packages.
We have an eye towards the
code and third-party ecosystem
that we discussed.
We give you notifications
when we find those
in a variety of ways
that we're going
to look through demos of today.
Supports Debian, Ubuntu, Alpine,
with Red Hat Linux and CentOS
on the way, integrates with
existing tools and workflows.
And we're going to see a couple
of examples of [? Bloove ?] how
we can do that.
And it's currently
available in alpha.
And there's actually going to
be a link at the end of the deck
of how y'all can go sign up and
try it out if you'd like to.
So enough jibber-jabber.
Let's go take a look at
the demo machine again.
All right.
So we talked about the image
I deployed with a whole bunch
of vulnerabilities.
I'm going to go over to the
Google Cloud Developer Console.
This is my Cloud cats project.
And what we're going
to see is a little bit
of interesting new UI that pops
up in the Container Registry
UI.
So for those of you
who aren't aware,
Container Registry is Google's
high-performance, secure place
to store all of your
Docker container images.
And that's what I'm
using for this app.
I'm under the ccweb directory.
And you can see all of the
images that I-- all of the tags
that I've pushed-- all of
the [? SHAs ?] I've pushed
for this particular container.
And you can see here 623
discovered vulnerabilities.
That's a big number, but
what does it actually mean?
And so I'm going to dive
in one level deeper,
and we're going to take a look.
Within that, 10 critical,
as rated by the CVSS score--
100 high, 417 medium, and you
can read the numbers on and on.
So we're going to give
you a detail for each
of the vulnerabilities that we
were able to discover inside
of the container, how
critical it is, if there's
a fix available, the
package, and then lastly,
almost most importantly, a
link out to the CVE document
so that you can read what
happened, how to patch it,
what is the actual risk.
So let's take a look
at one of these.
I'm going to click on good
old 4448, one of my favorites.
And we can see this is
a bug inside of libxml2.
It looks like it was vulnerable
in Debian Jessie, which,
for those of you who
follow along with Debian,
there's a Jessie, Stretch.
And then the latest is Buster,
but I don't think it's LTS yet.
Stretch, I'm pretty
sure, is the latest LTS.
But Jessie is kind of getting
a little bit long in the tooth.
So it looks like I
must be running on it
in just a completely old
version of Debian is probably
what's going on here.
But let's take a look at
a few of the other ones.
When you look through
the package names,
it's not just Linux,
or it's not just glibc.
ImageMagick-- my app
doesn't use ImageMagick.
Why am I getting a vulnerability
in ImageMagick for something
I don't even use?
And the more you
go through here,
the more you start to find this.
So I'm going to go through.
I'll find-- OpenSSH--
Well, I probably need that.
SqLite-- I'm definitely
not using SqLite.
It's a libvpx-- don't
know what that does.
Might be important.
And so what starts
to become very clear
is that I've got a
collection of problems
that are starting
to pile up here
that are leading to this
huge surface area of attack.
So if we go back to the deck,
how do we actually go and fix
all of these problems?
I mean, 623 vulnerabilities.
You can't just take
them one by one.
It turns out that
most of these fixes
fall into a set of
three common buckets.
The first bucket
is install patches.
Easier said than done,
but this is something
that you need to do often.
You have to do it daily in
your docker build files.
Add the good old app-get update
and app-get upgrade commands,
or for whatever distribution
you use and love most.
Update them.
Apply patches.
One of the great things
about the Kubernetes world
is that, it used to be
with virtual machines,
planning patch times was
actually kind of hard.
We may have to take the
product out of production.
Doing them batch over time and
handling all the restarts was
difficult. With a
containerized infrastructure,
there are all kinds of
tools built into Kubernetes
to help us handle this
and to make it easier.
So that's kind of
the first bucket.
The second bucket is
removing the packages
you're not actually using.
A stock Debian or
Ubuntu operating system
comes with a mountain
of stuff that
makes it great for portability.
Most applications,
most of the time,
can run on an out-of-the-box
installation of Debian
or Ubuntu.
But the cost of
that is that it's
got a ton of packages
you probably don't
need for your application.
And you really have to go
in and ask the question,
how many of those did you really
need, and can you remove them?
And lastly, and kind of the
most extreme case, which
we're going to take
a look at next,
is moving to a
different distribution.
Kind of, now that we've
started to understand
the ramifications of using
these giant operating systems,
we've started to look at things
like Alpine, Debian Slim--
smaller [? distros, ?]
less attack surface area.
So let's give it a
try, and let's actually
go deploy-- see what
it's like to deploy
a more secure container image.
All right.
So I'm over here in my
Cloud Cats application,
I'm going to go
into the Web tier.
And you can see here
I've got a Docker file.
Nothing too fancy-- as
I mentioned, node 4.
So let's go ahead, and
let's upgrade this.
Oh, running vi on stage,
what could possibly go wrong?
All right.
So instead of node 4, I happen
to know that 10 is the latest
version that's available.
So let's do that.
And instead of Debian--
the full Debian package--
I'm also going to tell it--
I happen to know that there is
an Alpine package out there.
Alpine is a much
smaller distribution,
supports a very tiny subset of
packages, but often just works.
Oops.
[LAUGHS] See, I got
what I deserved.
I got fancy.
All right.
So just as an example, I'm going
to do a docker build, example,
build the directory just to
make sure that everything works.
All right.
And it looks like it builds.
And then I'm going to run--
I have an update script
that does the build,
pushes it to Container
Registry, and actually
replaces the image in
my production service.
Out of sheer laziness
and a lack of desire
to type out the full
docker-push command,
I'm just going to
run that Bash script.
And we're building again.
We have Cloud cats.
Most of the layers
and GCR already exist.
And we're going
off, and we've just
rolled the whole thing out.
So now the new
version is rolled out
and available on
cats.jbeckwith.com.
Let's go take a look at what's
going on behind the scenes now.
So we can see we have an
image we just uploaded now.
First thing to take into account
is, hey, it's done scanning.
That was pretty fast.
We went from an image that was
300 megabytes down to an image
that's 75 megabytes
with the move
from Debian over to Alpine.
And most importantly,
I'm not going
to claim there are no
vulnerabilities, because that
would be foolhardy.
There were none found
against the known
list of vulnerabilities
in that version of Alpine,
that version of
Node, fully patched.
So we went from something
that had 623 vulnerabilities
by paying just a little
bit more attention
to what we used as the
base of our Docker image
and making sure it was something
we understood and where
it came from, we've reduced
the attack surface that much.
All right.
Let's go back to the deck.
So it's all well and
good that we fixed it.
But this isn't really
a good process.
Relying on me to go mill
around inside of the Container
Registry UI, discover that
there are vulnerabilities,
react to it, and then
just kind of hope
it doesn't happen again.
This is not a
strategy for success.
So the next thing that
we're talking about
is getting a good CI/CD
process that uses these tools
and takes them into account.
Every time that
we're shipping code
or we're developing
an application,
we go through this
natural evolution.
And you'll see slides like this.
You've probably seen them all
through the week with the Cloud
Build announcement
and the other things
that we've been working on.
We go from code,
we build, we test,
and then go into production.
And at each step
along the way, we
want to be able to make
the right kinds of checks
to make sure that we're
not making mistakes.
This is where the container
analysis API that we have,
which is part of our container
scanning infrastructure,
really becomes helpful.
When you do the build, we can
check what vulnerabilities
are available in this package.
We can write what's called
an attestation, or a sort
of statement of support
saying that, during the build,
we checked.
I'm giving it a
stamp of approval.
This has been scanned.
When we run the
test-- same thing.
And then lastly,
at deploy time, we
want to, again,
ask that question.
It's great that you're
trying to deploy a container.
Who built it?
Can you verify that it
was my build system?
Can the build
system verify there
were no known vulnerabilities?
Can it verify that
all the tests passed?
Can you verify any other
sorts of things that
are critical for my business?
Does it have the right licenses?
What promises can I make, and
what infrastructure is in place
to help me make
all of those checks
before I let this thing into my
production Kubernetes cluster?
So if that's all well and
good, we can now test--
going on, we have
a better process.
What do we do when a new
vulnerability is discovered?
So we have a couple of things
to help make this easier.
First, we use what's called
the activity stream inside
of the Cloud Developer Console.
You'll get a notification.
And this is, actually, if you're
enrolled inside of the alpha,
then you'll get this today.
And every time a new
vulnerability is discovered,
you can actually click
on that little bell.
It'll little show a little
alert with a number.
And you can go in, dig deep,
get information, use the UI
that we talked about.
The other thing
you can configure
are email notifications.
So I get a daily [? roll-up ?]
that has all of these security
vulnerabilities that are found.
I say all of-- traditionally,
I go fix them now.
And it lets me know
if there's something
that I need to work on if you
use email as your workflow
tool.
The one that we don't talk a
lot about-- which I don't think
many people actually
know we have-- is
we have a mobile application.
There's an Android app
that works fantastic.
And you can actually configure
that to get push notifications.
So if someone in your
team pushes something
that has a
vulnerability, if it got
past all of these
other controls,
you can actually get
a push notification
letting you know you have a
vulnerable image sitting out
there in production.
And then lastly, like
everything that we
release from Google Cloud,
there is a fully-featured API.
Now, the fully-featured
API lets you do
your typical CRUD operations.
You can create new
occurrences, create nodes,
read all the information.
You can do that on a loop.
But the one that we're
going to look at next
is our Pub/Sub API.
Now, what's cool about
this is, with Pub/Sub,
we'll publish a new
event every time
a new vulnerability is found.
And then you can use
that to integrate it
into any workflow, any
tool, that you want to use.
Let's take a look at how
I actually did this over
on the desktop.
All right.
So I'm going to go over
to Cloud Functions.
So Cloud Functions is
an easy-to-use functions
as a service product.
And essentially,
the idea is that you
can have very simple
hooks to execute
small, discrete pieces of code.
They've got a couple
of really cool launches
this week that you should
probably go check out.
One of the features of
it that I like the most
is that you can directly trigger
an event based off of something
coming into Pub/Sub.
And when you come
over here, you'll
see all of the
potential trigger type.
Instead of an HTTP
end point, I'm
going to look for a
Cloud Pub/Sub end point.
And then it'll just list all
of the topics that have already
been created.
Since we're in alpha
right now, it's
called resource notes
occurrences v1alpha1.
So yeah, I expect that you
will all remember that and be
able to go type it after this.
But it gives you
the dropdown list.
And what's cool is, now that
I have those events, now
every time that we get a new
vulnerability discovered,
I can go into here, write some
JavaScript, and react to it.
I'm not going to make you suffer
me writing JavaScript on stage.
There are other talks
you can watch me do that,
and people suffer through it.
But I've already
created a trigger that
actually goes and does this.
Let's take a peek.
So what I decided that
I wanted to see happen
is I have this code in a--
it happens to be in a
public GitHub repository.
Don't post your
security vulnerabilities
to a public GitHub repository.
This is just for
demo purposes only.
But what I'm doing is I'm going
to use the Octokit, the GitHub
API.
Every time there's
[? experts.newVuln ?]
a new vulnerability,
I'm going to
authenticate to GitHub.
I'm going to grab the
message that comes out,
and I'm going to go create
a new GitHub message.
So it'll just say "new
vulnerability found."
Let's see if it worked.
All right.
So here's the GitHub repository.
If you too want to be able
to put dogs against cats--
here it all is.
And we look at
(LAUGHING) issues.
OK.
I have 204 issues,
probably stemming
from some of the previous
images I had pushed.
You click in, and it'll give
you some of the API information.
From here, you could use this to
use the read API to go get all
of the information you want.
So if you wanted to integrate
with your existing bug
system, if you wanted to
integrate with your existing
alerting system, if you had
special things that you had set
up that you wanted to
use with Stackdriver,
you can use this API and
Pub/Sub and Cloud Functions
to easily kind of
glue it all together.
Let's go back to the deck.
So I'm taking this this time.
All right.
So that-- I think
that was the Reacting
to New Vulnerabilities demo.
So lastly, you can find the
vulnerability information
inside the developer console.
We talked about using the
mobile application and push
notifications.
We talked about customizable
API-based workflows
with Pub/Sub, and about
Cloud Functions just,
in general, being really good
glue for these sorts of things,
especially when
Pub/Sub is involved.
Now, you may be
thinking, this is great
if you're a GCP customer.
But what if you're
just running--
if you have Kubernetes, and
you're running it on premise?
Or what if you have
Kubernetes, and you're running
this on another cloud provider?
Well, what about open source?
That's great.
One of the projects that
we have that we have worked
hand-in-hand with just a
whole bunch of other companies
on defining is called Grafeas.
And Grafeas-- I'm going
to say the sentence.
"An open artifact metadata
API to audit and govern
your software supply chain."
What the hell does that mean?
What that actually
means is that we
have a consistent way
for vendors to tell us
what artifacts do we
have in our build system
and running in production, what
vulnerabilities are out there,
and what auditability
do we need to have.
And so you probably don't
just have Google Cloud
scanning your containers.
You might have Aqua Security.
You might have Black Duck.
You might have Twistlock.
You might have any
number of vendors
that are going and verifying
different pieces of information
about your artifacts.
This is an open
API designed to be
able to store that information.
And there's a reference
implementation
available on GitHub.
So the metadata types
and providers, they grow
and they change.
As we pick up new companies
and we work with them
and they ask to store
different types of information,
the standard has
been moving quickly.
We've had to open contributions
from JFrog, Red Hat, IBM, Black
Duck-- a lot of the companies
that we just talked about.
This wasn't done just to Google.
This is something that we
did with the community.
You can get a nice
bit of visibility,
both in terms of assets that
are your source code control,
all the way through the
build system to production.
And it can be used
both in the Cloud--
the container analysis API
we provide on Google Cloud
implements the Grafeas open API.
So taking that and connecting
it-- so it's great.
We have this open API, sort
of, database artifact analysis
thingy.
How do we connect
that to Kubernetes?
It would turn out
that Kubernetes
has this really cool
feature called the Admission
Controller.
It essentially sits in
front of any command that's
going to be run, intercepts
requests, and lets you
write a little hook of code.
The basic of it that, yes,
this looks good, or no,
get out of here.
Where this is really
great is for-- remember
how we were talking about
checking to make sure
that there are no
vulnerabilities, and that
who built the container?
The Kubernetes
Admission Controller
is how we can
actually go do that.
If you're looking for a tutorial
on how to work with Grafeas
and how to use that with--
and how to set up your
own instance of it,
there's a great tutorial
out there on GitHub
made by Kelsey Hightower,
who spoke here this morning.
I highly suggest to go walk
through that and check it out.
The next thing that we're
going to talk about-- we're
able to store the data, we
have this Admission Controller,
but you'd have to
do a lot of glue
to kind of put the
pieces together.
We are also producing Kritis,
another open source project
built alongside Grafeas that
makes it easy to take and check
assertions before running your
containers inside the cluster.
So you can test
assertions, plug directly
into the existing
Admissions Controller,
check build provenance, ensure
build scanning happened.
And also, there are just a
lot of neat little things
that you can do with it that
it's very easy to extend.
Again, open source, again,
available on GitHub.
So let's say that we
wanted to take our cluster,
and we wanted to lock it down.
Say, OK.
Justin, he deployed this
thing with Node.js 4;
it was terrible.
It had 623 vulnerabilities,
I think, was the number.
I don't want to let anybody
deploy anything into my cluster
if it has vulnerabilities.
And so we can create
a configuration
like this with Kritis that,
essentially, says this
is an image security policy.
There are some images I'm
going to tell you are just OK.
But other than that,
I want to make sure
that you do not check
in any containers that
have a high security
vulnerability in it--
just will not allow it.
But except for CVEs 1, 2, and
3, our security team looked at,
and they said those
ones were fine.
So I have this tight control
over what I'm allowed
to push into my registry.
And so let's actually take
a look at how this works
and how you can try it today.
Every time, back to the cat.
All right.
So I have another Google
Cloud project over here.
And we're looking at
some of the images
I have in Container Registry.
We're going to dig down, and
I have this rather benign
looking Java image that has
one critical vulnerability
inside of it and 31 others.
Again, the goal here was
to have a cluster where
I don't let anything like this
with a critical vulnerability
pass.
So I'm going to activate
them, and I'm going to use
activate the Cloud Shell.
If this is slow, I will
blame it on the Wi-Fi.
Word dance-- all right.
So we're going to go into here.
I'm going to take a
deep look at the image,
and I need to copy this.
I'm going to get the full SHA.
And if we look in
this directory,
you're going to see
that I have a pod.yaml.
And this pod.yaml,
all it does is
says this is the name of
the pod we're going to run.
Please use this image, which
matches the one that we had
pushed, and open up port 80.
So let's go ahead,
and let's try to start
our pod on the cluster.
I'm going to do a kubectl
create-f, pod.yaml.
And pretty quickly, it's
going to try setting that up.
It's going to take
a look at the image.
It's going to take an
uncomfortable amount of time,
and then it's going to reject
my request to create the pod.
And you can see here, the
error that we're getting--
"the admission hook,
Kritis validation hook
denied the request because
it found violations
based on our policy."
So now we don't have to worry
about who's deploying what
into our cluster.
We can give tight controls
on our cluster, both inside
of Google Cloud, and in our
own Kubernetes/Grafeas/Kritis
deployment and lock it down and
ensure that we have a semi--
a more secure environment.
Let's go back to the deck.
So what is the timeline
on all of this?
I mentioned that we're
currently in alpha.
All of the features we
saw today are available.
And you can use them
inside of the alpha group.
It integrates with
your existing images
that are pushed into GCR.
So if you're an existing
Kubernetes or existing
Container Registry customer,
we can actually turn this on,
and it all just lights up today.
To get access, you can join the
Container Analysis Users group.
And we're going to share the
link for that in a moment.
The things we're working on.
What's coming up in the works.
We had a lot of this we wanted
to get ready for this week.
It's not far away.
It's coming very soon.
The big one for me is
support for Red Hat, Linux,
and CentOS Cloud Security
Command Center integration--
so kind of bringing this
into the security control
stuff that's available
at the organization level
and plugging in all the
policy notification management
there and then just general UI
optimizations and bug fixes.
So to wrap this all
up, security is hard.
Any of us that have worked
in the field for a while
know there's one thing
that will fix it.
There's no silver bullet, but
our businesses depend on it.
We have tools that are going
to help you get through this.
We have the right
CI/CD offerings.
We have the scanner.
We're doing all of
this in the open,
and we want to do it with you.
And lastly, if you
want to join the group,
please send your questions
to containeranalysi
sfeedback@google.com.
One last, last, last thing.
We actually released
a new site today--
cloud.google.com
/containers/security that goes
way more in depth on everything
I talked about today as long
as a variety of other topics
extending all the way out
into the VM image, to
network security, to IAM,
to all of those other pieces
that we need to think about.
Really recommend folks
to go give this a look
and send us feedback because
we're really excited about it,
and thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]